what makes a star is often the subject  of speculation some radical minds have  even suggested that acting ability might  have something to do with it and their  argument is made more plausible but the  popularity of such dependable actors as  mr. Glenn Ford mr. Ford is on hand  tonight present the special effects  award ladies and gentlemen mr. Glenn  Ford the picture is nominated for the  best achievement in special effects our  deep waters 20th Century Fox special  visual effects ralph femoris fred surcin  and ed Snider special audible effects  roger hamer portrait of jenny the  Selznick studio special visual effects  Paul eager J McMillan Johnson Russell  Sherman and Clarence lifer special  audible effects Charles Freeman and  James G Stewart portrait of Jenny the  Selznick studio  Thank You Glen for